no matter what face are you laughs
you're currently in you're probably
battling a certain decision you need to
make in your life right now let me
explain to what I mean by this
maybe there's a relationship a job a
career or something's not gone your way
and you're not happy you are not pleased
you're disappointed you're hurt you're
frustrated you're agitated you're you're
flipping out already and you have to
make a decision and sometimes in that
moment the decision you make could
positively impact your short-term but it
may not positively impact your long-term
let me explain so in my career I've had
many times where I was upset because
some have I lost the count to somebody
else and this other person that took the
account they were in a manipulative
approach when they took the account away
and I was trying to do right when I was
so furious with this person so upset I
cannot believe you went to this place or
a business or relationship that went
with another guy that I know I love her
more than him anything like this that
maybe you're going through right now
okay
I would sit down and I would say Pat
what is your next decision that you're
gonna make make the options how are
these decisions going to affect you
short term how are they can affect your
long term some of the decisions you make
you're gonna be happy about it short
term because you can brag you can't brag
about it long term
eventually I made a decision that once I
put things into perspective I am betting
on long term decision here's why I fully
trust the process of long term fully I
100% trust the process of long term and
when you trust that if you continuously
keep doing the right thing if you
continuously keep delivering if you
continuously keep going above and beyond
and proving work and doing your part
trying to figure out strategies you're
learning you eventually I'm just telling
you eventually
favor goes to the people that make
decisions put things in perspective and
look at what's gonna happen that's gonna
benefit me long-term instead of what's
gonna make me happy short term
[Music]